no big deal you're just keeping a small
human alive yeah my name is Jessica
Francine I'm Tiffany I have three lovely
daughters I have one little boy who's
seven years old I have two boys women
are expected to fit into all these sort
of preordained injuries like the soccer
mom constantly yelling stuff out at the
field and Takai what to do a stage mom
my daughter's a star and so's my other
daughter I think throws my other
daughter fun mom would be someone like
me and fun wait okay
some people say I'm a fun mom it's like
they think I have a lot of other going
on it's okay if I say I think there's
daddy time they're like hippie dad's
suit dad dad bod is how tight the ones
that are involved this is my life my
kids are basically on me all the time
that's like perfect mom but mom I chose
to be a mother I don't need to think
drink it I'm cool you take a huge amount
of your time in a positive way but they
do go to sleep and that's when mom comes
out I like to go to the gym I play
sports I love skeet shooting reading
what we do that it's kind of like my
time just to relax online and just do me
you know more time for another yeah
there are so many people who play that
role of mothers for the friends of mine
that there's single parents she's like
well I do Mother's Day and then Father's
Day yeah I like Mother's Day Oh mamacita
or mamacita day oh those are some days
that you
leave your children with somebody break
a day right day month of stay let's
recognize the eighties I'm Mexican so I
won't have to say anyway I like that the
best ski for mother just do something
into your heart and with your thoughts
about me you like chose these yourself
she'll be like I picked red because Reds
our favorite color right and I'm like
yes those are the best gifts those are
the best gifts any gift that I get from
whomever is like the best thing and
people might think it's just knickknacks
but it's nice to all the symbol around
that beautiful gift that's my first
Mother's Day this year but I cannot wait
for my first macaroni necklace an
assumption I think people have is that
motherhood is more difficult than it is
fun we want to be yeah what are you
getting me for Mother's Day
[Laughter]